love entertaining I love entertaining
people I love to see you know people
being entertained therefore enjoy
entertaining how many times do I say
that yeah that was Derek Hough being
entertaining during his audition for
Dancing with the Stars ten years ago now
all the pros audition tapes have
resurfaced in boy oh boy what a
difference a decade makes what makes me
a great dancer
it's what I bring to the floor which is
I guess masculinity on the dance floor
I'm very wild aggressive and sexy but
off the floor
I'm very to myself mostly like a
all-american girl I will bring a whole
different dimension Youth energy the
obvious good looks and a full head of
hair would what sealed the deal for Val
wait for it
there you go and as for then 21-year old
Derek it was his charm we've watched
that babyface boy turn into a goatee
wearing six-pack Sport and six-time
winner I think when this good-looking
girl walked in I was like yeah this is
why I dance on the dance floor I am sexy
wild animal istic sensual and exotic
these audition tapes of our favorite
pros help them beat out hundreds of
other dancers vying for the reported
$5,000 an episode gig but the best story
may be max who we met back in 2006 let's
go this is what I could deal with Mike
seemed the great you see when Max was 13
he broke his leg in a sledding accident
and had a titanium rod placed inside it
he was told he'd have to walk with a
cane but six months later max was
dancing again yeah you can call that
determination
choose you looks you don't want to look
at me fine don't looking but I know that
99% of the rest are gonna love it and
deep inside you can love me too you just
lying to yourself because I am the man